this is the nation of chess or the
Capitol Hill autonomous zone who
recently changed their name to chop
[Music]
chess as the world's newest nation or
should I say was the world's newest
nation a nation that has already gone
down in figurative and literal flames by
the time you're watching this video
Chaz was founded in the heart of Seattle
by colonists I mean protesters some with
good intentions some would bad who
ripped away away from the indigenous
population of Capitol Hill in the state
of Washington an act I would make any
colonizer or imperialist very proud
what's really interesting is that
whenever a group of people try to take
away land from an existing nation by
force war almost certainly breaks out
chassé is a very special case flow not
only did the City of Seattle pull out
their police force without a fight after
several days of violent clashes between
police and the protesters officers
retreated from the area to de-escalate
the tension effectively abandoning their
station but the US government in DC also
did nothing as around six blocks of
their land was stripped away from them
like many popular revolutions chasse was
founded on some very noble causes ending
police brutality standing up against
racism abolishing the police not sure
how noble that last one is with even the
mayor of Seattle calling a new nation a
Summer of Love that is more like a block
party atmosphere it's not an armed
takeover it's not a military Hunta
not so noble was the fact that the
moment the nation was formed a border
wall was put up border patrol guards
with guns and for some very strict
immigration policies a monarch fill the
power vacuum their own brand new police
patrol the inside what what do you know
they're old pieces of police brutality
and of course some good old systemic
racism with things like black only safe
spaces thing is I'm half Italian half
Colombian so do I get a pass to get in
there or
right now home for just like oh just
black okay so full black you're saying
but don't be so quick to this Miss
Chasse because let's face it every new
nation faces their own challenges we
haven't even talked about their form of
government how safe it is for their
citizens if it's a business friendly
environment so you nation builders let's
give Chazz the benefit of the doubt
let's look at the economy of chess
rapes robberies and all sorts of violent
accent have been clearing any area they
were not able to get to it
for the first time in my life in Capitol
Hill I hear gunshots every single night
I've heard people screaming every single
night outside they're not protest
screams I've heard protests screams but
I've also heard like screams of terror
out there at the root of every country
and economy is the government the style
of government and the people who run it
determines how free the people or how
prosperous the people are and ultimately
how long a country will last in the case
of Chas or chop as they're now calling
it they first identified as an
autonomous zone now autonomous zone can
mean a few things in China they have
autonomous regions where supposedly the
local governments have more rights and
control over the land compared to the
central government in Beijing in the
case of Chas this is definitely not the
kind of autonomous zone they're
referring to most likely they're
modeling the idea of an autonomous zone
coined by Hakim Bey a writer that
promotes anarchism they explains that
these autonomous zones can be used as a
tactic by anarchists to sneak Anarchy
into formal society and subvert it
introduce a little anarchy or it could
just be the thesis centers one on a cool
name and they're just power hungry in
reality Chaz is more of complete chaotic
Anarchy with a little bit monarchy
oligarchy and direct democracy sprinkled
on anarchy is pretty simple there are
only a few Lawson chests and pretty much
none of them are written down they're
just generally understood by the
populace number one no police whatsoever
except for their own brenna police and
when they need help from actual police
of course number two you have to
completely submit to their Audiology or
else you'll be exiled or worse
so pretty much in Turkey the direct
democracy comes into play because the
desires of the majority is the only
voice that matters if the angry mob
decides to hold a black only safe space
that's what they'll do no need to deal
what pesky representatives or civilize
the Bates or people that disagree with
you no no no no in chess whatever the
mob wants the mob gets things moved very
fast here was chess was formed the
chassis ins found themselves with a new
monarch a warlord that declared his
power wrath Simone razz happens to be a
rapper that Owens million-dollar
properties in Seattle drops a Tesla and
apparently has plans to launch
businesses in the future kinda strange
that an apparent businessman would
support Anarchy which is bad for
business
but whatever every movement every coup
needs someone with resources and Raz is
that guy as shown here with him adding
out guns to his minions but brass isn't
the only one that's power-hungry in
chess as there are other people
challenging his world not obeying him
leaders trying to organize things in the
background they even have their own
official Twitter account so we don't
know for sure if brass is really the one
in charge over there if he isn't and
there's a group of leaders in charge
that will make chess more of an
oligarchy so what the government of Chas
down let's look at what chasse produces
do you know what did they make what are
they known for how does this economy
make money
[Music]
the Swiss are known for banking
chocolate watches the Germans are known
for their cars and their German
engineering
what about chess being that we don't
have official statistics on chasis
economy won't just have to estimate the
biggest industry is probably drugs after
all there's no rule of law in there you
can smoke and shoot up wherever and
whenever you want a lot of chasings are
just there to have a good time so people
are gonna need a lot of wheat and other
drugs that take I'm gonna try to not get
a contact high as I'm walking through as
it was the case yesterday there's a lot
of wheat being smoked there and someone
actually walked up to us and they said
where can we smoke and I said it's Chaz
I think you could pretty much smoke
wherever it is you want
Chaz also stressed to be an independent
nation that isn't reliant on foreign
imports so they have a very thriving
agricultural industry with their very
own illustrious farm other industries
include Street markets bazaars a very
popular street art culture and of course
you can't forget about the classic
business of extorting local business
owners for protection money we've also
received reports that these armed people
may be demanding payment from business
owners in exchange for some of that
protection our innovative chassis ins
took a page right now for the Mafia's
playbook so far these are the only
businesses and industries I could
discover in chess one reason for this is
simple the most important factor for a
thriving economy for an economy to be
able to attract new businesses new
entrepreneurs foreign investors is
stability after all if you're an
entrepreneur why would you open up shop
if you don't know whether or not your
business is gonna be burned to the
ground tomorrow why would you open up
shop if the government is unstable if
the country is gonna go to war or fall
apart soon stability is the name of the
game here and Chaz has none but don't
lose hope yet because chasis economy has
one thing that no other nation in the
world has the complete indisputable
support from another government sure
some countries get a lot of foreign aid
a lot or in alliances with other nations
but to my knowledge no other country has
ever gotten free toilets 24/7
electricity running water emergency
medical support all a hundred percent
provided by the government they rebelled
against so in a sense Chaz's economy is
relatively stable
it's bankrolled by the taxpayers of
Seattle
an economy needs is safety after all no
one wants to immigrate to a place that
isn't safe so let's look at that next
safety is of upmost importance the chess
says Chazz bans police and police are
needed to escort emergency services into
their nation they have to build a very
elite group of police medics and border
patrol guards from scratch we've heard
that there are people patrolling the
streets near 12th and pine but let's say
you're chatting and you get raped or
robbed or any other kind of violent
crime and you decide that well maybe
police are okay in this instance so you
called 9-1-1 well be prepared to wait
because they won't be able to get to
ever citizens are allowed to open carry
weapons as seen here what a guy swinging
around a machete so just make sure
you're packin 24/7 and I really do mean
that because the latest news at the time
of recording this video show that there
have been at least three shootings in
and around chasse one of them resulted
in a man bleeding to death because
police weren't allowed to escort
paramedics in and because chasse only
has a population of around maybe 200
give or take that means their murder
rate per capita is g500 per hundred
thousand people this means that chasse
has taken the throne from Venezuela as
the most murderous nation Venezuela had
a homicide rate of sixty point three per
hundred thousand people in 2019 says
chasse has a rate of five hundred per
hundred thousand people
that means Chaz is more murderous by a
factor of eight hundred thirty percent
Chaz is also very sanitary you've
already seen the porta-potties see I
don't provide it for Lum the city also
sent in cleanup crews at their own
expense very generous of Leung and at
one point Chaz Ian's even thought about
designating a dedicated area to do drugs
so if we're really into shooting up
start packing your bags ladies and
gentlemen there's also no pesky things
like freedom of religion so you don't
have to worry about outside religions
and cultures tainting your own a scene
here what the mob choking a preacher
face down
[Music]
so you know the government of chassés
you know the business and economic
environment it has you also know other
important factors like how stable and
how safe it is now the only logical
choice is to move the chasse and make it
your new home rates well not so fast as
we mentioned before the chasse Empire
has pretty much fallen athlete Louise
shootings the mayor claims that they're
going to take back the police station
the mob overthrew and dismantled the
entire occupation along with that local
residents and business owners are suing
the city for abandoning them so if
you're an aspiring nation-build about
wants to start your own chess if you
can't control the violence if you can't
keep the image of just a peaceful
protest you will be crushed see Chazz
did the smart thing by changing its name
from Chazz the capitol hill autonomous
zone to chop the Capitol Hill occupied
protests why because the leaders of
Chasse understood the importance of
public image their former name chasse
screams we took over your land and
create an independent nation that you
should probably invade to protect your
interests the latter screams this is
just a protest we're still citizens no
need to cut off the taxpayers money or
send in the troops so what are the
biggest lessons to take away from this
number one if you claim the site with
the angry mob whether that's true or not
anything is possible
all your opposition any authority will
bow down to you in submission and number
two before you start your revolution
make sure you have a detailed plan in
place to restore order and maintain your
power or else things will very quickly
descend into chaos
welcome to the watch the end club just
to clarify not everyone at chess wanted
to create their own nation some who know
we're there just to have a good time and
someone loved we're there to peacefully
protest like I mentioned before with
that out of the way if you enjoyed this
video consider subscribing because we
make video essays just like this one
every single week on the most
provocative stuff in the world business
or free W like this video you'll
probably like the other ones if you want
to support this channel financially
check out a course I made on how to land
a remote job that's how I got my start
in this whole make money online thing
and that's what I recommend for other
people too if you're wondering if I
stole this economics of type video
format from a channel called economics
explained it's because I absolutely did
Michael over there has a really great
channel and you can check it out what
you guess the link below this video
started out as being posting this video
idea on Instagram and you guys really
wanting it so here we are
if you want to vote on future video
ideas see some ridiculous memes more
day-in-the-life kind of stuff you can
follow me on instagram at Jay trend IO
that is gonna wrap it up for this video
thank you so much for watching you've
been awesome
I've enjoyed I'll see you guys in the
net
[Music]
[Music]